le mouvement MiTo moi aussi a vu le jour
non pas en 2017 mais bien 11 ans plus
tôt et c'est cette femme tanarabeurk il
travailleuse sociale de New York il a
lancé pour dénoncer les violences
sexuelles commises sur les petites
filles noires tout a commencé en Alabama
en 97 à ce moment en arabe et monitrice
de compte jour pour adolescente des
jeunes filles racisées et peu nanties ça
rencontre avec
Ivan 13 ans et décisive un jour la jeune
fille qui est réputée pour son
tempérament difficile demande à lui
parler en privé elle lui explique être
victime de violences sexuelles de la
part du copain de sa mère saaraba qui à
ce moment est elle-même survivante de
violences sexuelles la rejette au bout
de 5 minutes incapable d'accueillir sa
confidence
Ivan quitta le camp de jour et n'y
reviendra jamais
en 2006 tanarabeurk lance donc
l'association me too une initiative née
du regret de n'avoir pu répondre moi
aussi à hiver
il a pourtant fallu des années pour que
ce mouvement soit mis sous les
projecteurs dans la foulée des
accusations de harcèlement sexuel contre
le producteur des chutsteen cette
enquête du New York Times des langues
qui se délient une à la fois cette
publication de l'actrice alyssa Milano
dans laquelle elle invite toutes les
femmes victimes du harcèlement ou
d'agression sexuelle à y répondre en
utilisant le mot clic me too c'est le
début d'un phénomène social planétaire
même si dans une seconde publication
l'actrice a reconnu l'existence de Me
Too bien avant elle c'est la fracture de
2017 qui marque les esprits
souffrant est une survivante de violence
sexuelle tant était question de jeunes
filles de milieu défavorisées mais ça
peut susciter la même attention donc il
y a des questionnements à avoir
là-dedans des filles issues d'une
communauté où le fait de dénoncer et
déjà tabou ça peut être perçu comme une
trahison par des membres de la
communauté de dénoncer un homme de un
homme de la communauté noire par exemple
pour faire tomber ces barrières cette
intervenant de quoi qu'il faut miser sur
la prévention et des programmes
culturellement adaptés en tant que
survivante j'ai eu l'expérience d'avoir
mes expériences ou les expériences des
femmes autour de moi effacées par
incluse dans la conversation autour des
violences à caractère sexuel malgré les
défis les deux femmes continueront de se
battre pour que toutes les voix
compliquent ça inclut aussi les hommes
sont victimes de violences sexuelles les
personnes des communautés LGBT je pense
qu'on va écouter ces personnes là on va
vraiment avoir un mouvement qui va
pouvoir en fait libérer tout le monde et
non seulement une fraction de victime
ici Daniel Cadiot au Canada Montréal
[Musique]